ha hey guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Lauren gah and I'm Jeremy shine and
we're gonna watch the pokémon red and
blue with Smosh honest game trailers
I've seen honest trailers I've never
seen on his game trailers yeah this is
kind of cool
do you guys play Pokemon yeah hell yes I
played the red and the blue version why
was the blue my brother had the red ah
could you guys collect the cards I asked
you didn't collect the cards now who are
you doing with your life playing with
the Gameboy the cards were where the
game was really yeah I could have got
the ultra rare Charizard but I didn't I
could have stole it from my friend no no
not very modest no not how they tell me
I just remember when they had an ancient
Mew card the whole card is holographic
people paid so much money for that card
and then they gave it away for free
when Pokemon to you came oh oh and the
reason we're all together to watch this
one is because were the Asian ones on
the channel wait that's how it works
I'm half Filipino she's full Chinese
he's also half Filipino but we translate
more into the Asian side than we do the
white side so we're checking like 9 it's
like two Asians yeah you're only half
there's it's like three Asians but to
fully to fully installations yeah so
what better video than Pokemon cuz only
Asian people play Pokemon yeah in my
case it is that's what the yeah the
following trailer is rated H for honest
from Nintendo the company that's doing
fine what do you ask comes the game that
spawned five generations of sequels five
TV shows one Magic the Gathering ripoff
seventeen movies and a god pokémon red
and blue embark on an epic journey to
become a Pokemon sir
someone who beats wild animals into
submission trust them inside tiny prison
balls turns them into killing machines
and forces them to repeat the process on
their own brothers and sisters really
dumb if you think about it you've got to
catch them all
so trade your captured Pokemon with your
friends to become the very best
hey yeah how about I trade you my
Diglett for your Charizard or buy two
copies of the game to trade with
yourself like a friendless loser deal
huh jerk to the region of Kanto where
you'll interact with colorful characters
like Nurse Joy who hopes you keep ending
up in the hospital a brilliant scientist
who can't remember the name of his own
grandson and the rival pokemon trainer
has forge step into the shoes of red an
immortal child who never eats sleeps or
talks when you're sent away from home
you will do all kinds of things that a
ten-year-old never should like wander
alone through the woods strangers gamble
in a casino
hang out in the cemetery beat up other
kids pets for money and single-handedly
try to take down the Mafia
also the Professor Oak has more time
back home to bang your mom engage in a
turn-based battle system with all the
subtlety of rock-paper-scissors where
you can fine tune your team to have a
perfect balance of attacks then hit
stomp by that one kid who caught Mewtwo
so relive the games that started it all
if you're willing to override your once
a file or play to the barrage of sequels
that in tender will keep putting out
till they run out of colors or letters
starring 151 original Pokemon so hold on
to your butt's cuz we're doing them all
the one no one ever picked bloomin onion
plant asaurus grass
oh god my tail is on fire Charma
chameleons smell squirter Leonardo the
water Bowser The Very Hungry Caterpillar
what doesn't kill you makes you pardon
lower back tattoo smoking weed or kikuna
Matata Mohammed ah be a bird a big bird
a slightly bigger that Ratatat deadmau5
Britney Spears Pharaoh to the knee
snake spelled backwards Cobra Kai
Japanese Mickey wrong chew Taming of the
century
hurricane sandy jailbait barely legal
debate boy toy too plain Kirby tweetable
what does the phobic say miles nine
tails Prower lana del rey juice que ver
bees Edward Cullen turn up for what
Orlando Bloom black toad Paris Hilton
the flood evil Furby Mothra ticket three
little dick let's grumpy cat Kim
Kardashian Gangnam style Goldwing duck
Spanky my manky planet of the primates
Macklemore
Arcanine spin art this is your brain
this is your brain ah that's necessity
if there's one spoon there are two
spoons
judo chop Machop on roids
plant versus zombies nature's fleshlight
Venus dick track Japanese lunge Japanese
porn star Rocky Balboa pet rock
angry golf ball My Little Pony toy this
horse is on fire junior science fair
project Magneto's ball
haha bird with a unibrow holding a green
onion
doo doo Oh sir berteus kiss from a rose
Mountain Dew Gong grimace calm spell
backwards
Sheldon haunted vagina rick gastly dead
Wolverine evil stitch hooked on tonics
nyquil take rapist krabby patty Stage
five kingler a Pokeball al-qaeda execute
order 66 smelly pineapple mommy issues
Jack's going to Bruce Lee Jackie Chan
girl's best friend
honk itis lung cancer Ryback right don't
Teen Mom walking spaghetti monster
gringas carne water Bhutto hail Sidra
finding Goldie
desperately seeking Susan Patrick Jewish
star me
hi I'm a registered sex offender ah
paper cipher Nicki Minaj Buzzbee my
flaming button like a pincer bullsh not
living up to your potential
Gary Busey the Loch Ness monster
whatever you want me to be
Edie spelled backwards catfish rabbit
Chu fire crotch Asian polygon praise
helix baby Cthulhu headcrab Edwards
cipher hands
Sarah jurassica Parker diabeetus blue
jay leno shoes in spanish this bird is
on fire
droopy nee Puff the Magic Dragon air cow
without the YouTube space fetus and a
glitch in the matrix
did you mine and that's why I never make
direct eye contact with anyone
hey Smosh gamers did you know we do
movies to check out the honest trailer
for divergent over on screen junkies
I didn't think they're gonna play every
single character theme though yes those
chats a challenge because like it would
go from I don't know if I can handle
more - okay so now yeah and I was a good
one mad man got me again that was
creative Nicki Minaj is probably my
favorite they put a lot of thought of
tease me again damn I miss game boy me
too when times were simple and Game Gear
never play Game Gear
oh no yeah 36 minus 10 26 Game Gear was
a shape what game it was like it was all
right you want PSP imagine that but like
three times thicker and two times bigger
that's what she said
a manwich right now you're at a manwich
yeah I'm Anna manwich closer
manwich double penetration is a category
important in your dreams yeah get
inception her I we could inception her
it's a dream world so it might not feel
as bad it's true might be glorious anal
sex and vagina sex at the same time
anyway Oh clapping clapping we bump this
I feel like I'm in the way here
yeah how sexual hot yeah that's somehow
connects the Pokemon if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe here
hey and Lauren has a channel - I'm gonna
put the buttom right here yay Jimmy has
a channel - he read there by his [ __ ]
yay so yeah click on all three yay
shoutouts we're gonna do sous chef Javon
Lee job um your sex jokes are funny yes
thanks Jan please give me a shot behind
in this and so being so pretty Lauren
and Veronica to give me one too sorry
for being annoying Javon you are not
being annoying social agency comm
complimented Lauren yeah I don't care
about Veronica oh I care about Veronica
shots fired I care too much about I love
Veronica you must be black and Asian
Javad dude what a cool combo mix yeah
those are always the coolest what are
huge ins and huge dicks too man
you think yeah I could go its water
becomes Africa it's just an average size
on your right because black is huge
Asian is known to be small so then you
take the middle ma'am it's by Jeremy and
our halfway stop and say for the Asians
that it's true or his could be big in
short or thicken wait
tall wait you can have a tall penis
isn't it bad Jonas is like whiter than
it is tall there's a word for show yes
showed you sex shows are so funny
Lauren one day he likes you you will
admit that we had sex on camera one day
you will finally admit it
no we had amazing sex we didn't it was
the best it was the best sex Jeremy back
me up you were there probably because he
was dreaming we inception her yeah we've
already done it Bob Saget can i have a
shout out yes you can't even stop Saget
do you know how many life lessons I
learned from you I hope it's the real
Bob Saget that would be a end time
[ __ ] love you Bob Saget oh my god
dude that is so exciting
oh I never would have thought that you'd
be a fan of the show he's a comedian we
were quite entertaining ourselves yeah
you know like I love being in this home
but he really makes it feel like a full
house yes Lauren you don't like the
jokes just stop
don't make any noise or comments did you
shut up Bob Saget Darklord Varick oh
look at that
dudes the new Mad Max fury road charity
react
do it please can I get a shout-out for
recommending it please love your vids
well Dark Lord Varrick you my friend are
a dark God how interesting
now when you say dark are you like evil
or are you like a black god where is the
god of darkness yeah like you're the God
when the moon comes up that's your role
can you sleep during the day you
nocturnal yeah I hear that's pretty
unhealthy actually you have a better
sleep cycle circadian rhythms mm-hmm Wow
I'm smart yes she has a brain not just
an awesome body yep and a wonderful
smile hmm a great ass okay continue this
is the phone how many more I love your
style of fashion I'm in like big topics
lay my cake - yeah I know but you're
always like stylish at the end of the
band he's got cool kicks - there you go
converse high tops it's kind of a high
top day I'm Norma shooter I just bought
some low tops some white low tops I got
black low tops - they called low top for
just shooter tops
oh hi Johnson low tops mm-hmm no top he
missed that part of the party high-five
actually that happened there is there is
the part of the party with people to
have tops on there are no tops just keep
looking that way what did he do
nothing don't worry about it it was very
fun wait we're didn't work right having
a big time ginger oh yes my evening is
yesterday I also went to a party I'm
thinking about parents again teacher
back to back she is a party animal it
was like I was really kidding
also this happens okay wait wait what
he's about to oh I wish I guess is him
in the whole bottom I usually do that or
someone through there
do it that is very roughly got assuming
Jenga that they had written out a
standard here here we go let's see man
oh no my friends who party it was they
had Jenga and they wrote like truth or
dare stuff on it uh-huh
and that that was the Dare that I got it
that's a great one so I got to
experience that so that was fun they
must have fun drawing on you yeah I
guess
wow you were passed out I wasn't passed
out oh we just did her phone that was
the dare that was the Dare yeah where it
was like Jenga we had written stuff on
it like take two drinks or like get
slapped and one of them was just dare
and and the girl dared me to get a penis
jaw - on her stomach
yup that just happened first she said
drop penis on your arm and then somebody
else thanked thankfully chimed in and
said at least draw it where she can hide
it so but then I showed you also your
well I'm very didn't know yep that
happened are we ending this video for
right I don't anymore she today we did
three shadows I think I was three okay
well uh thanks for watching guys
this is subscribe to our channels who
cares about this one yes thank you